on sait depuis longtemps que redchef
tayyip erdogan se pose en homme fort sur
le plan géopolitique refusant les
concessions il met en avant la puissance
de son pays quitte à parfois éveillé
indignation mécontentement et polémiques
plus de cent ans après ils refusent
toujours de reconnaître le génocide
arménien qui a pourtant fait de 1,2 à
1,5 million mort de manière parfaitement
documenté aujourd'hui son soutien envers
l'azerbaïdjan dans le conflit qui
l'oppose à ces mêmes arménien n'est un
mystère pour personne
reste qu à l inverse des azerbaïdjanais
les arméniens sont chrétiens ce qui
tendrait à accréditer la thèse d'un air
de ran champion du monde musulman
une thèse qui veulent vite en éclats
quand on se penche un peu sur la
question en 2019 frère de ran menacé
d'écraser la tête des kurdes pourtant en
première ligne du combat contre des shu
menées par une coalition censée être
allié d'ankara
s'il ne se retirait pas des zones
frontalières de la turquie promesse
tenue puisque la répression militaire
contre les kurdes à la frontière turco
syrienne avait été rude les violences
envers les forces kurdes en syrie était
bien réelle elle avait fait au bas mot
150 morts
cette opération s'était adjointe de
l'installation de deux millions de
réfugiés sur les terres kurdes
l'écrivain français patrice franceschi
qui a effectué de nombreuses missions
humanitaires dans la région avait alors
parlé de nettoyage ethnique
le mois dernier alors que la perspective
d'une présidentielle anticipée prenait
de l'ampleur en turquie et que le parti
d'erdogan semblait en perte de vitesse
plus ou moins 30%
ce dernier a multiplié les actions
contre le parti politique opposant kurde
uhd paix à ne pas confondre avec le pkk
partisans de la violence
en procédant à pas moins de 80 2
arrestations de militants de ce parti
raison invoquée avoir en 2014 donc il y
a 6 ans maintenant appeler les turcs à
descendre dans la rue en signe de
protestation alors que la ville kurde de
coban et subissait le siège de dèche
en turquie les kurdes ne sont pas les
seuls à être l'objet des foudres
d'erdogan
rappelons que le coup d'état manqué de
2016 a donné le coup d'envoi de purges
impressionnant dans tout le pays ont été
visés l'armée ces putchistes bien sûr
mais également ses opposants
intellectuels universitaires artistes ou
journalistes en juin l'assemblée
parlementaire du conseil de l'europe
estimait que 95 d'entre eux étaient
actuellement emprisonné en turquie à
tous les tribunaux ne font pas de
cadeaux mi juillet on recensait plus de
2500 personnes condamnés à la perpétuité
et diverses peines de prison pour 1600
autres suspects depuis le coup d'état de
plus de soixante dix sept mille
personnes ont été incarcérées selon les
échos et plus de cinq cent dix mille
gardes à vue ont été prononcées pour
soupçons de soutien au coup d'état
pas sûr que les yéménites n'ont plus
perçoivent totalement les aspirations
humanitaire d'erdogan qui soutient
l'intervention saoudienne contre les
rebelles chiites houthis qui a fait
depuis 2000 15 cent mille morts selon
nombre d'estimations et a été qualifié
de pire catastrophe humanitaire au monde
à l'onu alors air d'orane champion des
musulmans c'est peut être vrai pour
certains mais sans doute moins s'ils
sont le malheur d'être kurdes ou chiites
ou tout simplement opposants